listen I'm a fan of both of your work uh
but there's going to be people out there
that have never seen it so if someone
has never seen anything you've done
before what is the thing you want them
starting with and why oh that's a great
question
uh start with uh I guess casual
um I it's I mean I don't know if that's
uh I don't know if that's a great
indicator of what I do because I did
kind of come into this business as a
comedian but I I I I loved that show and
I think it's just uh I think that is a
great show so I think if you're gonna
introduce yourself to my work
um yeah start with uh some great writing
and a great cast and great directors
it's all indie film directors on on
casual and starting with Jason Reitman
who produced it and uh and I think it's
like a great show because it sort of
centers a brother sister but the sisters
in her 40s and and with real woman
problems not bullcrap women problems and
uh it's very honest and I was very proud
of that show I don't know what to say
it's four seasons of fun but yeah what
would you go with
I mean I guess I would go with
succession yeah
succession or inventing Anna yeah I mean
in seventh grade I did
um okay and there's a VHS of it floating
you gotta find it I was in a chorus and
music man it was called Give My Regards
to Broadway it was a review
um all right I have a question for you
um how hard was it for you to get inside
the role of an insecure actor very easy
super duper duper fast quick
um I mean to be honest it's it's it's
being an artist is just full of insecure
I mean there's I don't care who you are
like I've had the great privilege of
working with Robin Williams and I could
I saw his insecurities you know like
everyone's got it because we're always
trying to strive to be better
um no matter where you are and so along
the way as good as you might think it's
going you're like oh wow
wow I really sound like that wow you
know I was just saying that that I'm in
a play right now uh a doll's house and
sometimes in the middle of the show I'm
like well everyone realizes that I'm a
fraud so it never ends that feeling
never ends God isn't that something so
so crazy isn't that something and that's
why I come from improv and sketch comedy
as well as theater background and and I
was doing a show recently and I had to
be backstage because it's been a while
and I was afraid I was going to go out
there and really just
you know craft the bed and I remembered
oh I know how to do this like I I I've
put in my 30 000 hours or whatever they
say you know like I can do this but I
I'm like how is it that I've been doing
it this long and I still have to like
put myself up and go on stage you know
totally yeah it's so it's I find it so
fast and I've spoken to so many actors
and I find it fascinating that no matter
how high up on the food chain you're
always thinking about it but maybe
that's what keeps you you know that's
what I think it is actually I think it's
it's a hung it's a real hunger for
trying to to try to get better you know
what I mean um and just you know and and
that and the older you get you know more
vulnerabilities are put out there and
you know more insecurities can be you
know so it's almost like if it stops
being scary yeah are we done yeah yeah I
don't know so I'm a huge fan of Nicole's
work and I am very curious what is it
like reading her scripts for the first
time and seeing the way she's able to
just it like it's unbelievable how she
is uh able to portray these real
relationships and you know so honest and
complicated and I'm just curious what
it's like reading that on the page for
the first time I mean I I get tickled
like genuinely tickled I'm like because
it's like the insight and the Nuance of
characters relationships between
characters her observations like you can
tell Nicole is sort of
um who is that guy on 60 Minutes who was
always like you know what I don't like
oh yes that guy David um uh no uh it was
always like the last segments yeah it
was oh uh I wanted to say it was uh
is it Andy Rooney it might be yeah like
just again okay yeah yeah like I feel
like that's a character in Nicole's
brain I was like you know what uh and so
there's all these tiny tiny tiny little
observations that she makes throughout
her film where I'm like
it's so true like I never throw out my
underwear
um because
there's a there's a line where I say he
even throws out his underwear she's like
you know and Ice I was like it's true
like if I spent a pretty penny on a pair
of underwear I don't care how if it's 40
years old I still move it from house to
house or apartment never wearing it but
I was like that was expensive I should
probably keep it hold on to that one
one of the things about this film is
that you're filming in New York City and
I'm curious what is it actually like
filming in New York city has the city
reached a point where like they no
longer you know care when you're walking
by with a camera do people actually you
know what I mean totally
um 100 we were shooting outside of
Paragon and some gentleman who was
wearing a mask at the time but it was
like you know we were just we're like
please the p is like please can you move
out of this
shot because this won't work and the guy
said move to a studio
I was impressed you knew at a studio
yeah exactly oh well you know
and and then we're like okay well New
York here we go baby I mean that's the
beauty of shooting in New York on
location in New York is just the most
exciting dangerous insane especially if
you have no money yeah then it's really
like good luck out there yeah it's just
a fun like experiment a walk and talk
where you you're stepping over a dog
poop yeah oh yeah you know and people
are just giving you the fingers yeah
that must be nice uh I definitely want
to know uh what do you think for each of
you what do you think happens to Beth
and Dawn
um I think they get super powers and
then take over the world in a you know
they're they're sort of like a Mr and
Mrs Smith kind of thing yeah that's
exactly what's gonna happen next that's
that's it we don't want to spoil it but
that's you hurt my feelings I think they
I think quite honestly I think they work
work through something you know I and if
I were to guess
it's a fight that's going to resurface
probably two or three times and it's
gonna escalate because it's always gonna
be like well except for that time that
you lied about are you lying to me now
about about my hair like you did about
my book you know I bet that's gonna
happen but amazingly I think actually
both of the couples are like really
great models of what a good relationship
could look like because I think they
will work I think that will happen but I
don't think that they will break because
of that yeah I think they will keep
pushing forward and I think that's
what's so kind of magical about the both
of the couples I think there's a lot of
love yeah about between the couples in
this in this movie yeah a lot of love
here a lot of love there and I just
think it's and a lot of love between the
sisters and the brother-in-laws which is
very sweet you know and the kid the
kiddo yeah there's and our mother
despite her fuzziness like there's a lot
of love in this movie even though
everybody seems to be quite pissed all
the time yeah exactly yeah I I think one
of the things is that the all the people
in the movie communicate very well yeah
and that's that's uh unfortunately some
relationships are not like that but you
know communication is the key to
everything yeah it's my last thing for
you and it's Michaela I'm just curious
what is it like reading in the script
you're going to do a walk and talk and
also have to eat ice cream because the
ice cream you know that's not one take
yeah that's great I have no problems
with eating lots of ice cream if that's
your question I was a little bloated
later I am lactose intolerant but um
yeah but I didn't care and then Nicole
would come in and be like are they just
gonna throw it out and then she would
take big mouth and just shove the my ice
cream cone into her mouth during covet
it was great
everything about that is amazing
I have to stop with you guys I just want
to say um the movie's fantastic
um and I hope it's a huge hit and thank
you for giving me your time thank you so
much thank you so much